hier soir au palais des sports
un jeune boxeur battu par ko au premier
round a peut-être vu s'envoler sa
dernière chance de devenir un grand
champion
nous sommes allés lui poser quelques
questions alors ça va un peu mieux
oui aujourd'hui ça va mieux j'ai fait
des compresses
c'est ma femme qui m'a soignée elle a dû
être déçu votre femme elle a été
surprise elle matin des petits bonheurs
à on peut dire que ça a été rapide
le combat a duré combien de temps
exactement deux minutes neuf secondes
enfin haute et 10 secondes pour le ko je
pose mon 9 je retiens ça fait une minute
59 deux côtés on est plus vite rentrer
chez soi parce que traîner sur un ring
et puis au vestiaire et au bistrot c'est
pas une solution non plus surtout
pourrait sportif
que pensez vous de votre adversaire un
type très antipathique tout de suite il
m'a déplu des enjeux les 10èmes tueur à
mieux respirer mieux c'est mon manager
je lui dois tout celui qui m'a trouvé
mon surnom puis djibil moi je m'appelle
maurice c'est comme johnny hallyday
c'est de le poids johnny hallyday je le
sais je les lis beaucoup
c'est monsieur ramirez qui m'a fait
découvrir la lecture
tu dois tout la boxe la culture wingene
bill et à soi il ya des mal élevés qui
m'ont appelé painting balle s'ils
croient me démoraliser tu vas bien et ce
malgré l'opinion du vaincu sur le
vainqueur
vous n'avez pas tout dit sur lui un type
odieux
j'aime pas
r c'est vrai on est tous des frères mais
celui-là ailleurs enfin je suis pas le
genre à porter plainte
est ce que vous avez sais rien j'ai du
mal nous recevoir en tombant il m'a tenu
une châtaigne dans la figure une
méchanceté
si tous les boxeurs du monde voulait se
donner la main une boutade
parce que y'a l'idéal et puis la dure
loi du fric comme biais monsieur ramirez
ya soir ça a été tellement vite je n'ai
pas bien réalisé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je sais pas si
lui qui a commencé un garçon plein de
poils partout d'abord un genre
épouvantable c'est vrai on sera animée
que ray c'est simple il s'est jeté sur
moi vous aurez krugier pas que j'avais
dit du mal de lui je connaissais même
pas comment je faisais un petit signe
janil à la télé vous avez la télé mais
on a la télé je la paye avec mon
tempérament
louis
je viens juste à la caméra pour ma femme
interlude plus de son plus d'image on
m'a tapé dans l'oeil et 10 secondes
ça passe vite quand on un sommeil parce
que la boxe s'est jamais que je le type
i poke pour gagner c'est plus du sport
il faut pas se prendre au jeu
moi je m'amuse c'est moche et libre à
tout petits pas des blagues mois pour
boxer il faut pas être sorti de
polytechnique ya la tête et le ventre
enfin le foie l'estomac
je vais pas entrer dans des détails
anatomiques
alors oui quand je me protège la tête
comme j'ai des bras trop petit j'ai le
ventre à l'air mais versement j'ai plus
qu'à fermer les yeux ou alors il ya des
gens pour se replier moi et moi je tiens
c'est pas pour me donner des coups de
pied dans les chimères jeudi en carriole
thuram y rester je suis un des plus
rapides au tour de ring trouvez vous
votre défaite
j'ai jamais eu destin sauvage je refuse
la violence
déjà quand j'étais petit mon frère me
frapper j'ai appris ma mère alors hier
soir comme thuram us a crié aux puf et
au plus fait des bonds c'était pas mal
parce que moi j'avais la tête ailleurs
j'ai pensé à autre chose je pensais à ma
petite patricia qui vient de perdre de
temps comme son papa l'autrui entendu le
premier il a cru que c'était pour lui au
buffet qu'est ce qui moi me
pourquoi êtes-vous devenu boxeur au moi
j'étais pas chaussé jénine et monsieur
ramirez qui m'ont poussé lui stoneham
ils n'ont pas un ami du côté de ma femme
d'ailleurs ils ont très intime et fois
je vais au cinéma est avec un papa quel
sens bête
jeanine ça lui donne démissionne le
cinéma ouais c'est monsieur ami e s qui
m'a fait découvrir le cinéma tout le
temps il m'envoie au cinéma c'est lui
qui me l'a fait découvrir sa et les
livres je dévore simple sur ramires
serait jamais qu'une brute c'est lui qui
me l'a dit je dévore littéralement
teilhard de chardin tolstoï est ce qui
en fait un homme maxence van der meersch
genève en jeu déborde
j'adore ça mais la boxe est un sport qui
comporte bien des vicissitudes
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant je vais écrire un livre où je
raconte des choses de ma vie c'est pas
ce qui manque
j'ai une tête comme ça